kamme is a modern horror film that
showcases the dangers of social media
sharing culture and identity theft the
film is currently making waves on
Netflix and throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything you need to
know about the ending of the movie there
will be heavy spoilers and this film is
definitely worth checking out with fresh
eyes so if you don't want anything
ruined you have been warned but everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to set within the world of internet
cam modeling we follow Alice aka Lola as
she tries to unravel the mystery behind
why another online account has managed
to completely duplicate her boys look
and more this replica goes above and
beyond wireless would normally do and
proves dangerous to her reputation as
Alice investigates deeper she discovers
that another cam user named baby girl
may be behind it so our protagonist sets
out to discover her identity
Alice however discovers that the real
baby girl died six months earlier and
when contacting her top friend tinker
learns that there's a pattern emerging
between the deaths of cam girls and the
appearances of their replicas we
eventually discover that the Menace
replicating the girls is actually a
complex algorithm that is able to
duplicate users after months of study by
the end of the movie Alice engages in a
faceoff with her clone over the Internet
to prove which is the real Lola Alice
wins the contest and gets the password
to a clones account which enables her to
delete it and finally be free of the
copy however in the closing moments of
the movie we see that Alice has created
a new account and is ready to re-engage
with the public once more to me this
highlights the dangers of addiction to
social media that we as a people have
grown to have even I can admit that I've
probably spent too much time online
attempting to betray a certain image and
it's easy to get invested in this
digital world where we present our
perfect selves and seem to be loved
because of it alice is a victim of this
and it comes back to haunt her heavily
the fact that she uses a pseudonym
highlights that the digital version of
ourselves is make-believe
and even she knows it something put in
place in order to hopefully catch the
attention of others so we can become an
objective desire what cam does
beautifully is it highlights the dangers
of this and how we ourselves begin to
believe that our digital self is more
important than the real world palace
becomes trapped in this and clearly
we'll become stuck in a loop where the
algorithm will copy here again similar
to this we know that social media
platforms are constantly using data to
target us to consume they know all of
our personal information sell it and
have the potential to hold us to ransom
with it and we still don't care and keep
using the platform's what I love about
cam is that it highlights these dangers
and reminds us that this is a scenario
not too far away in a world where
everything can be faked
it's a beautiful reminder that perhaps
we should keep things private instead of
putting them all over the pages of
Facebook Twitter and more so what are
your thoughts on cam did you enjoy the
movie and what did you take from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please check out
my breakdown of the crimes of
Grindelwald which will be linked at the
end of this video this is a channel for
people who are man into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]